[Music]
well Rihanna has her own idea for a racy
royal wedding gift and she told us all
about it at the New York launch of her
savage xfinty lingerie line we have a
bridal vibe going on definitely do her
in the top situation but I mean really
on your wedding night you could do it up
it depends on Savage you want to be I
[Music]
think you have to go to the extreme when
you're getting for both a man and a
woman because both people benefit from
the gift
RiRi was definitely feeling her sexy
self wearing the lingerie she designed
the 30 year old is hard at work just
four days after she owned that Met Gala
red carpet dressed as the Pope and RiRi
revealed this style secret it was heavy
every step was a squat I promise you it
my butt ain't exactly it's a lot of work
and a lot of I mean and beating you know
I appreciate the art so I had another
option that was a lot
simple seemed Margiela it was so great I
couldn't deny which man named wall which
real name Abel
next up Rihanna's promoting ocean to
eight with Sandra Bullock eat lunch at
and the rest of the ladies but was she
left off the girls group text chain
we're very open they're all on this
chain
Anne Hathaway gives great gift we have a
bit of that text change the movie unless
they like took me off with a girl chat
some mistake I don't think they they
will because I I'm their friend we don't
have any beef or anything that I know
about
[Music]
[Applause]